what's the longest you you've had to
be quiet in the position not moving
what's the longest you went
uh
one and a half weeks
how long
in afghanistan you're not moving or
standing up walking nothing
no 10 days you're just laying there
that's correct
how are you eating how are you peeing
how are you
you end up paying yourself you defecate
in a in a tupperware jar so basically
you roll over your number two will put
it underneath you you defecate in it he
wraps up you put it in your backpack
um you dig a trough between your legs
and then when you pee it sort of like
goes down the trough so it doesn't
hinder you um you eat
dry food all the time because you don't
want to cook you don't want smoke to
give your
signature away or anything so you eat
cold food
and you catnap through the day so you'll
he will he will be on the scope you cut
that for 20 minutes
and then you swap and change and things
like that craig one and a half weeks you
so for one and a half weeks you guys are
not talking you guys are not commun
nothing everything is non-verbal and
you're laying there
that's correct yeah the only um time you
get to speak is when you send sit reps
on the radio just to make sure that you
know everything's going okay um and
you're sending um
sit reps all the time on what the
enemy's doing all the time so that's the
only time you get to speak
how special was this assignment where it
required you to be that patient was this
a special assignment in afghanistan
yeah yeah
to stop the uh afghans getting weapons
um this village we were looking into um
the the afghans will get really um a lot
of weapon systems into this village and
then they'll distribute it
around afghanistan once it gets into
this village so our job was to
gather lifetime information
of what's going on find out who the main
people are and um eventually take them
out did you eventually complete your
mission on this on this in this case
yeah we did yeah yeah
and this was one target or was it
multiple targets multiple multiple how
far were they from you where you're
situated at
closest was about 675 yards and the
furthest was about a mile away
so 675 yards that's seven football
fields away from you the closest
yeah and and where are you are you on
top of a mountain are you by trees are
you in the desert what's the situation
like when what we used we had these um
these cam nets
and basically these cam nets
if you turn them
one way they keep the heat in if you
turn the other way they keep the heat
out so we managed to cut
a big section of this cabinet to cover
ourselves up
and we're on a ridgeline so we're quite
high up elevated looking down into the
village
but we had support
to our um left
of major weaponry but they didn't get
involved it was more of a sniper op than
anything else how many how many people
was it that you took out on this one how
many uh what was the number
oh wow
got it so this so from the moment you
knew was ready this uh the week and a
half goes by
the the 13 confirms what is the timeline
from the first kill to the 13th one
she's you're talking
it all depends where they are at the
same time
it was funny because they had a um
a big heavy machine gun called a gsc 17
and it's an anti-aircraft gun
and it holds um clips of 30 mil rounds
and there are only four
in afghanistan the that the
taliban had
and the sas destroyed two
um in theater
and then there were still two out there
and they had one in this village so as
soon as we took the first target out
they they had a rough idea where it came
from the the the from
the noise
and um
they opened up with this asg-17 and took
the whole ridgeline out um you're
talking
probably four meters
in front of us was just it was all
splashing up we were getting shot we
just kept our heads down we didn't move
or anything
and then at the night time we
withdrew out our position and we went
into another position because we were
you know worried that we had been seen
um or been compromised
but um you're talking 13 people with
probably within a space of
um
within 10 days so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you